- [Presenter] I'm here with
Jeffrey Rosen, the head
of the National Constitution
Center in Philadelphia,
and what I wanna talk about
in this video, Jeffery,
is how has the powers of the president,
how have they changed over
time since the ratification
of the Constitution?
- [Jeffery] Well, they've hugely expanded
and it's so striking that the
Framers of the Constitution
were concerned that Congress
would be the most dangerous
branch and they were
so concerned about that
that they split Congress
in two and created
this bicameral legislature,
the House and Senate,
in order to divide its powers.
They would have been stunned
to learn that the president
is twice as powerful as Congress today.
They created a unitary
executive because they were less
concerned about Executive
than congressional tyranny
and it's really interesting
to think about why that,
why that happened.
- [Presenter] What do you
mean by the president today
is twice as powerful as Congress?
- [Jeffery] Well, I guess
that was a hypothesis,
but it's arguable that,
having assumed powers
to deploy troops without
congressional authorization
to target and kill
American citizens abroad,
to engage in Executive
orders without congressional
approval, critics of the
expansion of presidential power
say that the president has
usurped congressional authority,
he's exceeded his power
under the Take Care Clause
of Article II, Section
3 of the Constitution
and that in this way,
presidential authority has hugely
expanded while congressional
authority has contracted.
- [Presenter] I see.
And what are, I mean, what
are the dynamics that allowed
this to happen over the
last several hundred years?
- [Jeffery] Well,
there's a wonderful essay
on the National Constitution Center's
Interactive Constitution by
William Marshall and it's,
you can find it if you click
on Article II, Section 3,
and William Marshall
is trying to figure out
what some of these dynamics
were, and he comes up with
a bunch of reasons why the
president has been so dominant.
First, he says political
culture, the president
has become the focus of
national power and culture
in a way that he wasn't in a
pre-internet, pre-television,
pre-radio age, and this
was the case even during
World War II when Justice Jackson
Steel Seizure Case that
we talked about before,
talk about Executive
power having the advantage
of concentration in a
single head in who's choice
a whole nation has a
part, making him a focus
of public hopes and expectations.
But there's no question that
the focus on the individual
person of the presidency
has vastly expanded.
- [Presenter] It's just this idea
that there's one person there,
people associate that
person, hey, they're our
Head of State, they put their
hopes and fears on that person
and that just gives them
inherently more power.
- [Jeffery] It does and
you can call it culture,
you can call it celebrity,
but it's so striking that
the Framers are so concerned
that the president not be
a king and they reject
Alexander Hamilton's suggestion,
which again (chuckles)
we know from the musical,
that the president be elected for life.
They wanna have four year terms
and then the, subsequently,
a Constitutional amendment is
passed, the 22nd Amendment,
to limit the president to only two terms,
and despite all that, the
presidency has expanded so much.
It's not only the political culture.
Marshall points to a
bunch of other reasons.
Executive branch precedence,
basically every president
has been successful in
asserting increasingly sweeping
exercises of executive power.
This is a bipartisan phenomenon
from President Clinton
to George W. Bush, to President Obama,
the Office of Legal Counsel
in the Justice Department
has authorized increasingly
sweeping exercise
of executive authority,
and we find presidents
of both parties either
criticised or praised
for having established these
executive branch precedence.
There's also just the expan--
- And just to make sure.
- Yeah.
- [Presenter] I wish
to understand, I mean,
it's just this idea that even
if you were just president,
I come in into office, I
might even be more restrained,
but then the next guy or, or
gal (chuckles) that comes in
can cite you presidency
and say hey, he did it,
why shouldn't I be able
to do it, so there's this,
it's never gonna go back.
Precedent will never take you,
take powers away, (chuckles)
they'll only add to them.
- [Jeffery] That's exactly
right and this really important,
but not so well known office,
the Office of Legal Counsel,
which several Supreme Court
Justices have been the head of,
is, basically, a mini-Supreme
Court for the executive branch
and it issues opinions about
what the president can do
and those opinions are relied
on by subsequent presidents
to justify the expansion
of executive power.
- [Presenter] Fascinating.
- [Jeffery] Not all presidents
have taken this view.
I'm writing a book, now,
about William Howard Taft
who was the only president
who went on to become
Chief Justice and he thought,
he had a very literalist
or judicial conception of the presidency,
he thought the president could only do
what the Constitution
explicitly authorized.
He refused to take actions
that he thought weren't
authorized by the Constitution,
and in this sense,
he gives us a vision of
what a more constitutionally
constrained presidency would look like.
- [Presenter] But even though he did that,
as we were just talking about,
people who came after Taft
could just cite people before
Taft (chuckles) and say--
- [Jeffery] Absolutely right,
and Taft's predecessor,
Theodore Roosevelt, had the
most sweeping conception
of the presidency.
He said the president can
do whatever the Constitution
doesn't explicitly forbid and
his stewardship conception
of the presidency definitely
has been vindicated by time
and you'd have to say
presidents today are much more
Rooseveltian than they are the heirs
of William Howard Taft. (chuckles)
- [Presenter] Yep.
What other dynamics are at play?
We talk about political
culture that celebrity
into one person, this precedent
that keeps expanding powers.
What else?
- [Jeffery] Well, there's
the huge expansion
of the Federal government,
and the administrative state,
and the growth of the executive agencies
in the post-New Deal period from
the Environmental Protection Agency,
and even progressive-era agencies,
like the Federal Trade Commission
or the Federal Reserve,
and work place safety,
National Park management,
smoke stack emissions, college sports.
There's almost no area of American life
that these executive
agencies don't regulate.
The president, by appointing
the head of these agencies
and having the ability to fire them,
can issue executive orders
that have the force of law,
even though they're
not passed by Congress,
and that can lead to
really dramatic clashes
between the president's
use of executive orders
and what Congress says
that it actually intended,
as we've seen during the
Obama administration.
So that's a big factor, as well.
- [Presenter] Yep.
And what other dynamics are there?
- [Jeffery] Well, the modern
world is moving a lot faster,
in an age of the internet
and instant communication,
there are a lot more emergencies,
attacks are much more
sudden than they were
at the time of the framing
and have to be repelled more quickly,
so just the speed of contemporary life
has led to the president to
assert new emergency powers.
And then, finally, and I'm just
tracking William Marshall's
great essay, here, there's
the rise of partisan politics.
Because of Congress becoming so polarized,
often people in Congress
see their responsibility
to support their party
rather than to take seriously
their Constitutional
or institutional duties
as legislatures, so they may
be unwilling to, or check
the president's power when
their party is in the majority,
they're just willing to write
the president a blank check
when he happens to be a
member of their party.
- [Presenter] And I can see
that when it's the same party
in charge of Congress and the presidency,
but what about when it's
the other way around?
Obviously, in recent time
it seems like the, Congress
is being very effective
at limiting presidential power.
- [Jeffery] Well--
- [Presenter] Because
of partisan politics.
- [Jeffery] You do have
either congressional inaction
or refusal to act on
presidential proposals,
but often, critics of
congressional inaction complain
Congress is refusing to veto
bills, for example, or sorry,
to override presidential vetos
or to refuse to pass laws
on constitutional grounds.
Instead, they're filing lawsuits,
they're kicking things up
to the court.
When President Obama
issued his executive orders
about immigration, there
was a lawsuit filed.
So, increasingly, the judiciary
is becoming the arbiter
about disputes between
Congress and the president.
The Framers expected a
much more direct clash
between the president and
Congress and thought that both
of those branches of
government would make decisions
on constitutional grounds
and would directly
check each other.
- [Presenter] It's this idea
that instead of Congress
passing legislation and then
the president either signing
them or vetoing them, that
when you have this gridlock,
that the president starts
taking more executive orders,
and then Congress take
the president to court
(laughter)
over them.
- [Jeffery] That's very well stated
and that's definitely not
what the Framers intended.
- [Presenter] This is
really, just to go over them
once again, when you just
have one person in charge,
and this is, it starts with Washington
who was this huge personality,
obviously American hero,
and so that, by itself, put a
lot of power in the president.
Then every president
comes along and maybe does
a little bit more (chuckles)
than the ones that came before it.
And then anyone can cite that president,
hey, he pulled it off, why can't I?
As you mentioned, the
Federal Government is far,
far, far larger than
it was in the time of,
when the Constitution was written
and in the time of
Washington, and just the speed
with which things are
happening, it's necessary
for a president to, whether
it's in war, or regulation,
or other things, to just be
able to take action quickly.
And then finally, partisan
politics, I guess,
that one could, it seems that
could be debated either way
depending on which parties
are in power where,
but it is fascinating, it
does seem like this has been
a very clear trend over time.
- [Jeffery] It's true.
Those are all great reasons
offered by William Marshall
in his interactive Constitution essay.
There's one other factor
and that is the fact
that both branches, the
president and Congress,
are not evaluating their actions
on constitutional grounds
the way they used to.
The president has the veto
power under Article I, Section 7
and at the time of the framing,
the presidents often issued
vetos on constitutional grounds.
President Andrew Jackson
who vetoed the re-chartering
of the second bank of the
United States vetoed it
on the grounds that he could veto any bill
that he considered
unconstitutional and he sided
with Thomas Jefferson's view that the bank
was unconstitutional,
rejecting the view of Hamilton
and George Washington that is was okay.
But nowadays, presidents
tend not to issue vetos
on constitutional grounds
and Congress tends not to
debate bill in constitutional
terms and as a result,
critics on both sides of the aisle say
both branches are exceeding
their constitutional powers
and failing adequately to check
the constitutional excesses
of the other branch.
- [Presenter] That's fascinating,
something I never fully appreciated that,
what you mentioned is historically,
Washington, and Adams,
and Jefferson, they viewed
their veto as kind of like
a light Supreme Court, a
little bit, like is this
constitutional or not, and
that's why I'll veto it.
But then later presidents
started to say, no,
if I just disagree with it,
I just think it's a bad law,
I will veto.
- [Jeffery] Absolutely, and
this idea that the Supreme Court
is the sole authority,
arbiter, of constitutional,
of the constitutionality of laws
would've surprised the Framers.
They had a theory of departmentalism.
They thought that all three
branches had an obligation
to evaluate the constitutionality of laws,
that Congress, when they passed a bill,
the president, when he signed it,
and the courts, when they reviewed it,
and only when all three branches agreed,
could a law go into effect.
But that, now, we tend to punt
all constitutional questions
to the Supreme Court and
that has left something
of a vacuum on the side of the
president and the Congress.
- [Presenter] Well, thanks
so much for this, Jeff.
- [Jeffery] Thank you.